it's great to be joined today by Jason
Stanley who's a professor at Yale
University author of the book how
fascism works the politics of us and
them also author of how propaganda works
knowing how both of these things work is
a particular importance right now I
would say Jason and I think may be a
good place to start is when we think
about fascism and maybe authoritarianism
as well we can have elements of those
mechanisms in society without literally
having a fascist dictator that is in
place right can you talk a little bit
about how one does not require the other
absolutely so my book how fascism works
is is based on an analysis of fascist
politics and rhetoric so not what a
fascist dictator does because there's
many different things that a fascist
dictator does but even fascist
when you have fascist politics and
rhetoric and ideology floating around in
the public sphere that's harmful for a
democracy because ultimately democracy
is a culture it's a culture that
respects liberty and equality we read
respondent foundational to liberty and
equality is truth so it's a culture that
respects truth because without truth you
can't speak truth to power
fascism by contrast is when you when you
have fascism in the public culture then
it starts to wear down the democratic
culture by wearing down our respect for
our mutual respect for truth our mutual
respect for a shared reality and our
mutual respect for one another our
mutual respect for our fellow citizens
so democracies ultimately a culture it's
not a voting system because if you have
no if no one respects the truth and no
one and everyone is just spiked filled
with conspiracy theories then who cares
how they vote it's not gonna like reveal
anything right
democracy's a culture and when you have
when you have people of filling the
public space with conspiracy theories
raising panic and fear detaching policy
from reality
in favor of advancing their own power
then you wear down a democratic culture
and when you wear down a democratic
culture even if you're democratic
institutions are fairly robust you still
have a worry for the future of your
democracy yeah so I think this is great
context for the conversation we're going
to have in analyzing what's taking place
today which is we are talking about
called a culture of fascism or
authoritarianism not an actual fascist
dictator in the sort of 20th century
historical sense and and thinking along
those lines if we can what are the signs
that you are seeing moving over the last
several years that should be concerning
to those who don't want that type of
society to develop well we have what the
fascist the scholar of fascism Robert
Paxton calls staples of fascist
movements in our politics we don't have
a fascist dictatorship we have a robust
opposition party that that one a that
one the midterms so we have a robust
opposition party we have robust
democratic institutions but we have
there's two worries about our
institutions and that would be number
one the attack on our voting system
loader suppression voter
disenfranchisement pana rent always
warns warns that a sign of a fourth of
totalitarianism is when politicians
betray loyalty to party over parties by
which he means loyalty to their own
political party over a multi-party
system and I think we are seeing too
much loyalty to a political party when
you see Americans more loyal to their
political party than they are to their
democracy that's a worry that people's
that people's faith in democracy has
eroded so that's one thing the kind of
party loyalty we're seeing which is very
dangerous
more specifically about fascist staples
we're seeing politics that is completely
detached from reality we're seeing the
in in recent days to take an example of
mr. Trump's speech about the wall we're
seeing the manufacturer of crisis and
what is crisis but an opportunity to
suspend normal rules we've been here
before in the aftermath of 9/11 when we
suspended rules about enemy combatants
moments of crisis are perilous moments
for democracy and we've gotten too used
to in this country suspending normal
rules for claims of crisis be they
terrorism financial crisis as in
Michigan the disaster that led to Flint
Michigan an emergency manager to deal
with a financial crisis we should have
absolute lines in the sand about
constitutional about national
emergencies because those are moments
that allow undemocratic actions by
definition to occur we're seeing a
rhetoric of vicious xenophobia directed
against the immigrants which is always a
sign of it's an invariable sign of
fascist movements that kind of
xenophobia too cos it's a classic
because there's an appeal there to
purity to a pure ethnic national past
where the country was great and it's
been ruined by liberalism by feminism by
immigration so we're seeing that classic
rhetoric we were once great we were once
an empire I mean you saw this you know
Hitler mine Kampf is all about this
about Germany was once great he talks
about lacks immigration rules have
ruined and ruined the country Jews
bringing in non-whites into Germany by
Locke's immigration rules so we're
seeing classic staples we're seeing
rallies mr. Trump's rallies chanting
rhythmic chanting rather than sort of
discussion of policy details we're
seeing the a car seat a replacement of
truth and devotion to democratic ideals
with loyalty like you know when people
say you know you know I mean
the President himself ever since he ran
for office has been has been talking
about his bond between him and his
supporters and that's not a bond you
want a politician in a Democratic
Society to have so let me know that's a
few to get us kind of started so let me
make an opposing case to allow you to
tell us why this is not just politics as
usual in the United States the chanting
to kind of go backwards yes we can
we heard chanting when it was Barack
Obama right so the chanting alone is not
really a sign politicians lying
alternative facts etc you see if you
find the pro Trump enclaves of the
internet the refrain that listen
everybody lies we just are more
comfortable with the fact that Trump is
doing it for the greater good but it's
not unique that Donald Trump is lying
using fear and emergency to try to
achieve political wins that's not
particularly new I mean you know we
could go on but I guess the question is
is this a matter of degree or are we
truly seeing something different here
it's a matter of degree because in all
in the United States I mean I verted in
my formal remarks to the dangerous
moment following 9/11 in moments of
genuine crisis there is always a concern
about anti-democratic takeover and we
saw that with Vice President Cheney we
saw you know we saw in under the Bush
administration harshly anti-democratic
measures so now you have an element
about the chanting about the S we can
about the hero-worship well so people
like to use the term populism and
there's an element in all successful
politicians runs for office of populism
so of course President Obama had a cult
of personality as well however when
Steve ban and said we got elected on
build the wall and lock her up um I'm
not sure that President Obama got
elected on yes we can I think President
Obama got elected on Christ a financial
crisis on a sense that the
elites had had just you know completely
destroyed the country and we're not
paying for it and so so there was a it
was a moment that was a moment of crisis
and Obama promised a different direction
in contrast what we have now is a
manufactured crisis so you've got to pay
attention to to reality as I said
democracy requires a firm grip on
reality and and that brings us to your
next point about lying there's lying and
there's lying this president goes to
very to great extremes yes you know
President Obama you know misled us in
many ways he was much more connected to
the financial industry than the
Americans who elected him might have
wanted there were they're all democratic
politics involves concessions
wee-bey there's big money in politics so
all democratic politics involves
involves you know stretching the truth
making the common interest seem like
making the interest of your donors seem
like the common interest but right now
we have an unprecedented scale of lying
that is that is destroying and the the
problem is it's destroying any respect
for the truth in politics that anyone
had so mr. Trump supporters President
Trump supporters I agree they recognize
that he's lying and they read and they
think he's doing it for a greater
purpose but what's happening is no one's
gonna get punished for lying anymore and
when no one even pretends to tell the
truth then we have a real worry
I mean before President Trump I think
one break the lying and the conspiracy
theories in the manufacture of crisis
has gone to a different level here
because because what we're seeing is
we're seeing people not caring at all
earlier you had to pretend you weren't
lying you had to maintain some kind of
consistency from day to day but we have
an open attack on the truth
the president is saying you're with me
or against me and it doesn't matter what
I say you know you just believe in me
well that actually you know when when
you in hearing you talk about that I'm
reminded of there's been a bunch of
analyses done about is what we're
experiencing now more like George
Orwell's 1984 or Aldous Huxley's brave
new world I'm more of the mindset that
it is becoming more like brave new world
than 1984 I'm curious where you would
fall on that why do you say that well in
1984 it was very clear who provided the
so-called truth right you had the
Ministry of Truth or what it whatever it
was called now I'm actually forgetting
was it Ministry of propaganda ministry
of many true I believe it was called
master true but the circumstances brave
new world was one where there was almost
not even a desire anymore to figure out
what is it actually that we should be
paying attention to what is it that
matters and that seems more like the way
that it's going now that's absolutely
right
uh you know those of us who study
Russian propaganda know this that the
goal is not to have an alternative
narrative but just to destroy the very
idea of narrative at all just to replace
all respect for truth by who's your guy
who's your man who do you support
who's your team that's the goal so
Timothy Snyder in his book the road to
new book the road to on freedom talks
about employ what he calls in plausible
deniability when he says when Vladimir
Putin but talks he's often saying things
get saying things that are completely
implausible and his audience knows that
and they enjoy it because it's a show of
strength what he's trying to do is he's
trying to not not impose some sort of
weird counter narrative but just spit
out so many different stories that no
one knows what to believe anymore and
all they're left with with the idea is
with the idea that's our guy we believe
in him yeah not so torn out a white flag
where you say it's almost too difficult
to figure out what the truth of the
facts are so I'm just going to stick
with the per
that I think has the rhetoric that
resonates with me in some way that's
right who talks who uses the terms who
uses the chance that I agree with now as
you said it isn't just a chance it isn't
just yes we can I mean I think it's
there's a degree of difference here
there's a degree of like how much did
president Trump went on policy proposals
and how much did he win on you know
talking about the cities burning
immigrant rapists another aspect that
we're seeing now is we're seeing the
normalization of vocabulary that should
never be normalized in a liberal
democracy that should never be
normalized in a country that that has as
a value equal respect now if you look at
the literature of the European extreme
right like yeom phase Y 2001 why we
fight these are toxically white
supremacist books they talk about he he
Guillaume Fay recommends to politicians
to to far-right politicians to use the
term aliens for non Europeans he says we
have to make people recognize see what
these people really are they're aliens
they're not like us they're alien
intruders our our government from the
White House on down from the Oval Office
on down uses a term illegal aliens to
describe human beings that is
terminology that you know should not be
used in a liberal democracy that has
equal respect as a chief value versa
that this is actually a big piece of how
this administration communicates
political ideas the strategic use of
these types of terms absolutely
absolutely and we're seeing more and
more of these terms from white
nationalism enter into the vocabulary
obviously we're seeing nationalist and
globalist enter into the vocabulary so
we're seeing a lot of we're seeing
attacks on the Liberal Democratic norm
of equal respect under the guise of
political correctness
so and we're frankly being conditioned
to as the Bush administration did as
well so this is not new and and
President Obama with drone strikes and
our foreign policy has been dehumanizing
people for a long time but now we see
the tension between having a liberal
Democrat democracy and being a country
that kills a lot of people it becomes
easy to lose your grip on the
fundamental democratic value of equal
respect this is just a fraction of the
great discussions that are in Jason
Stanley's books how fascism works the
politics of us in them and how
propaganda works Jason really appreciate
you taking time to talk to us about this
today thank you very much great
discussion